thank you
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
is this Joe Rogan's Comedy Club comedy
Mothership I love you to understand
what's so significant about it like
what's the big deal he just opened up
the club but it's going to be the first
club that I know of I think it's gonna
be the first Club ever where it's owned
by a comedian yeah yeah that didn't just
open it so he could get stage time and
it don't need to make money bro it's
about to be the best club Joe Rogan's
new comedy club The Comedy mothership is
finally set to open their doors to the
public tomorrow after nearly two and a
half years of preparation tickets to the
club's first round of shows went on sale
last Friday and were sold out literally
within seconds yeah could you get Joe
out here the comedy Mothership has two
different stage rooms named fat man and
little boy plus a bar named after Comedy
Store icon Mitzi Shore fat man holds
around 240 seats and little boy fits
about 100 they are probably comparable
in size to the or and belly rooms at the
comedy store which is dope but that also
makes me fear that getting a ticket to
actually see a show at the comedy
Mothership before they sell out is gonna
be really difficult for a really long
time I think club might turn into the
comedy version of the sneakers app we
got really good people here brought uh
Curtis Nelson and Adam eager and uh you
know Eric from The Comedy Store all
these people from The Comedy Store uh
carry to run the bar like I brought the
best people that were at The Comedy
Store because it was during the pandemic
nobody was working right I said hey this
is what I'm gonna do do you guys want to
work for me and so like for the last
year and a half they've been actually
like working for free like like they're
been getting they've been getting paid
right but they haven't working they're
not working they've just been waiting to
just holding them right but I kept
giving them their full salary right like
I said this is not your problem you know
we had an initial venue that fell apart
so we had to buy a second venue and the
second venue required considerable
construction so I said listen this is
okay for all the lucky fans that are
able to snag some tickets to the
Mothership it sounds like going to a
show will be the ultimate Comedy Club
experience in addition to the lineups
being stacked every night we have Tim
Dillon Ron White Tom Segura Christina
przitzki Tony Hinchcliffe David Lucas
William Montgomery Hans Kim Joe Rogan
spared no expense when it came to
opening this club he started off by
hiring all the best people that worked
at The Comedy Store to come work for him
in Austin including his new president of
operations Adam eagitz Joe also
mentioned that he'll be providing a
service to lock audience members phones
during the show which usually makes her
a better all-around performance and even
Louis CK had a helping hand in giving
Joe some pointers on building the
ultimate comedy club for comedians you
at one point in time thought about
opening up a comedy club
yeah because you're opening one here
yeah you thought about it when when I
saw the Babe Ruth movie with John
Goodman did you ever see that movie no
played Babe Ruth and I don't know how
much truth there is in it but he wanted
to manage a ball team and uh he John
Goodman was such a good actor and he
does this moment where he says I just
wanna I love the guys I want to take
care of the guys I want to be the guy
who looks after them and and you know
trains them and T you know and make sure
they're okay because he just love ball
players I thought I watched him do that
and I thought that's how I feel about
comedy the location of Rogan's Club is
right in the heart of Austin's comedy
scene on 6th Street in the former Ritz
Theater there's an entire history of the
building on the comedy Mothership
website that's really interesting it
goes all the way up to present day where
it reads in 2022 the building was bought
by comedian podcaster and commentator
Joe Rogan during the following year the
building was renovated under the design
of Austin architect Richard wise to turn
it into the comedy Mothership a stand-up
comedy nightclub destination fulfilling
a dream and vision Joe Rogan had of
providing a comedy community here in
Austin that would draw comics from all
around the world if it was Joe Rogan's
dream to form a comedy community in
Austin that would draw on comics from
all around the world it's definitely
coming true on top of all the other
great comedians shows already recruited
to Texas it's now been officially
confirmed by Joe himself that none other
than the Rat King theovan is on his way
to town Theo moved to Nashville Theo
Vaughn but was there a comedy scene
there a little bit a little bit a little
bit you know but like there's Nate
bargatzi who's fantastic he's there but
uh Theo's gonna move here now so it's
like he's excited about it too and if
that wasn't enough it's now being
speculated that the number one Live
Comedy podcast in the world killed Tony
will be adding a second weekly show
every Thursday at the comedy Mothership
it's exciting because it's new and all
these young people that come here and
they do kill Tony kill Tony twice a week
is gonna be huge it's huge for them
obviously doing double the amount of
shows is going to be huge for their
growth it's going to be huge for Joe
Rogan's Comedy Club getting a host them
every single week and it's going to be
huge for the already thriving scene of
young comedians in Austin they'll now
get a chance to be seen by the hundreds
of thousands of kill Tony fans twice as
often the first kill Tony episode to be
recorded at the mothership will be on
Monday March 13th in the fat man I feel
like Austin is
maybe not third place but in that top
three now what is it like just a normal
week
um comedy scene here it's amazing I mean
Joe Rogan's flies out Mark Norman or I
shafir Shane Gillis they come here a lot
Tom Segura lives here Tim Dylan has a
house here uh some of the best comedians
in the world are on that Joe Rogan show
it's become really really a good place
for comedy and with the Rogan Club
opening up it'll only get better the
Legion of skank's YouTube channel was
removed again by YouTube last week the
skank shared the bad news on Twitter
saying quote sadly YouTube has removed
our Channel we'll be appealing the
removal and hopefully be back soon but
right now the only place to find our
video content is at
gasdigitalnetwork.com there's yet to be
any official reasoning given for why the
channel was deleted I think at first we
all just assumed that YouTube was trying
to censor the Legion of skanks based off
their style of Comedy but the people of
Reddit seem to be pretty convinced it
was because of an error made by one of
the producers who allegedly left porn
running on one of their streams if this
isn't just Lewis trying to trick people
into using the gas digital website it
really sucks that YouTube took down
their Channel hopefully the appeal goes
well hopefully it'll be back up soon but
for now I guess we should just have to
wait and see guest spots from last week
your mom's house had on Chelsea Lynn two
bears one cave was Bert and Howie Mandel
kill Tony tonight is with Roseanne Barr
flagrant had on Charlemagne Mark Norman
was the guest on stavy's world Chris
O'Connor was on Matt and Shane's secret
podcast Chris DiStefano is on the blocks
podcast and Chris's Stefano was on bad
friends with Bobby Lee here's what's
going to happen for the for the time on
this podcast because I'm I'm gonna be
Andrew Santino but I'm gonna be a little
bit different and the key difference is
guess what I'm going to be the Andrew
Santino who isn't mean to you I'm going
to be the Andrew Santino who's nice to
you and he doesn't have a compilation of
of him yelling at you on the podcast
which I don't support I'm gonna be nice
to Bobby Lee yeah well could I just say
this yes is um you don't have the
ability to do it even if you wanted to
because I don't have that in me you're a
softy I'm a soft and he's mean yeah
you're gay this past weekend with
theovan had on logic The Joe Rogan
Experience talked with Russell Brand
whiskey Ginger had on Michael Pena David
Cross was on the Honeydew Ryan Hansen
was on take your shoes off with Rick
Glassman Ari shaffir was on we might be
drunk Colin Quinn was on you know what
dude with Robert Kelly Brian Quinn was
on are you garbage and Krista Stefano
was on the joke World comedy news update
last week we interviewed him on this
show so yeah as far as new stand-up
specials go maybe the most anticipated
special of all time took place on
Saturday March 4th Chris Rock's elective
outrage was live streaming from
Netflix's website it was the same night
as a stacked UFC card so many fans were
split on what to watch but for those who
tuned into Netflix who saw Chris Rock
doing his thing live holy what a
show of course now everyone's talking
about how Chris Rock utterly dismembered
Will and Jada in the funniest way
possible in front of everyone live which
is great but it should be known that the
entire special start to finish his world
class every joke was hitting so hard and
you could just tell Chris Rock was
pumped to be there doing this live on
Netflix for the first time the live
aspect was really really cool it made it
feel like you were almost watching a
sporting event at times but it was
comedy usually a special for Netflix
would be shot like three different times
and then edited for months this was raw
footage it felt real it felt like being
at the show and there was really no
technical difficulties maybe two or
three stutters I think Chris messed up
one joke towards the end but overall it
was definitely a success and I have a
feeling Netflix is going to want to
replicate this model with more comedians
moving forward well that does it for
this week's joke World comedy update as
always thank you so much for watching
this video and we'll be back again next
Monday with some more comedy news let me
know in the comments what you think of
kill Tony doing two episodes a week I
think that's going to be huge I think
it's going to be dope I think a lot of
cool shit's about to happen in Austin
and around the comedy Mothership Joe
Rogan if you're watching this I would
like a job better please I could be I
could be in charge of the phones I could
hold the phones during the show I could
I could clean the mothership whatever
the mothership needs I will do I already
got the outer space comedy theme going I
don't know
could be the move Joe let me know
turn on the posties post notifications
the posties the post Malone is because
we got two more videos maybe three
coming out this week that you're not
going to want to miss
see you later
[Music]
foreign